hatrick for you TV in the last three
rounds you missed the podium we were
discussing about this by an inch but
still an amazing finish for you assess
your tournament assess your performance
and I know you want to analyze this game
because it was so
nice uh yeah I don't know how to assess
my tournament I have to think about it
um the middle of the tournament was very
bad for me I think I became uh
demoralized maybe a little too early um
okay I lost to people who are winning
the tournament so result wise it's not
too bad but uh I also left a lot of
points on the table um some one move
blunders like my game against bee I just
blundered a lowed her to Checkmate me
and my game against Talia which was just
such a disgusting blunder and such a
breaking point for me in the tournament
um but also I play I think I played some
good games I think of course this last
part was good for me my game against
Alice was definitely a highlight for me
uh so it was definitely up and down
tournament but uh rating wise has been
good so at least that's I'm very happy
about absolutely and a three-oh finish
especially this last game against
Grandmaster an eight-time National
Champion Arena crush this was an
attacking Masterpiece tell us where were
you sure that things are going your way
in this position because it wasn't clear
right she had her chances on the queen
side as well but you were pushing and
you were creating a lot of threats and a
lot of chances on the king side and in
the center how did you assess this
position where did you feel you're
taking
over well I wasn't expecting she'll play
the time on I was pretty sure she'll
play the con she played it last two
times we played um each other and she
played it with good results so I was I
was happy to see this because I thought
it'll be more combative uh so when she
went F6 like I had a feeling you don't
play F6 in this position because you
know things aren going well for you F6
is a s of desperation I'm not sure if if
Bishop H3 is the right way to go I think
it is because I think there's this
pressure on this D7 Pawn okay I guess
it's not I did spend a lot of time on
this move this is something I feel in
this trend every time every time I spend
a lot of time at the critical moment I
make the wrong decision so what am I
supposed to do if not Bishop H3 Rook to
G1 same type of idea just create more
tension on the G file and on this side
but rather with Rook G1 than Bishop H3
at the same time things remain very
complex even at this point Bishop C5
Queen to D3 and now Bishop to B4 I think
this was the mistake Bishop takes C3 she
was supposed to play It's all about
exchanging the Queens right so but I'm
not going to allow her to exchange the
Queens but then I move I go Queen D3 or
something again can I take on3 maybe
even if I take on G5 you lose that
so yeah but this is good for
black I guess we both didn't really
assess the position correctly and it's
not easy it truly is not easy it's a
very imbalanced type of position but yes
after Bishop to B4 Bishop to F4 you
conducted the attack uh very precisely
with that move Queen to G3 uh Rook HD1
to put pressure on D7 Rook G Queen G3
and then the checkmating uh final attack
final sequence congratulations TV quite
an amazing game this was guys any
questions
thank I think just incredible
performance that congratulation on the
really nice finish
absolutely yeah for me uh this game